[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parlez-moi de la pluie et non pas du
beau temps le beau temps me dégoûte et
me fait grincer les dents le Bel Azur me
met en rage car le plus grand amour qui
me fut donné sur terre je le dois au
mauvais temps je le dois agir upit il me
tomba d'un ciel
d'orage par un soir de novembre à cheval
sur les toits un vrai tonner de bres
avec des cris
putoir allumer ses feux
d'artifice grandondissant de sa couche
en costume de nuit ma voisine aollé V
cognère mon nuit en réclamant mes bons
offices
je suis seul et j'ai peur ouvrez-moi par
pitié mon époux vient de partir faire
son dur
métier pauvre malheureux
mercenaire contraint de coucher dehors
quand il fait mauvais temps pour la
bonne raison qu'il est
représentant d'une maison de
partenire en bénissant le nom de
Benjamin
Franklin mise en lieu sûr entre mes bras
Colin et puis l'amour a fait le
reste toi qui Simme des partenaires à
foison que nanas-tu planté sur ta propre
maison erreur on ne peut plus
funeste quand Jupiter alla se faire
entendre ailleurs l'appelle ayant enfin
conjuré sa frayeur et recou ouvrez tout
son
courageent dans ses foyers faire sécher
son mari en me donnant rendez-vous les
jours d'un tempséri rendez-vous au
prochain
orage à partir de ce jour je n'ai plus
baissé les yeux j'ai consacré mon temps
à contempler les cieux à regarder passer
les nu à guetter les stratus al
les Nimbus à faire les yeux doux au
moindre cumulus mais elle n'est pas
reenu son bonhomme de Marie avait tant
fait l'affaire tant vendu ce soir-là de
petits bouts de fer qu'il était devenu
millionnaire il avait en mené vers les
cieux toujours bleus des pays imbéciles
où jamais il ne pleut où l'on ne sait
rien du
tonur Dieu passe que ma complainte aant
bourbattant lui parler de la pluie lui
parler du gros temps auquel on a tenu
tête
ensemble lui chantit qu'un certain coup
de foudre assassin dans le mille de mon
cœur a laissé le dessin d'une petite
fleur qui lui
ressemble
[Applaudissements]